a Pap test is a test to screen for  cervical cancer or other cervical  diseases your cervix is the lower part  of the uterus at the top of your vagina  a Pap test  to check your cervix for abnormal cells  abnormal cells can sometimes turn into  cervical cancer if they aren't treated  a Pap test can be part of a pelvic exam  first your health care provider will  place an instrument called a speculum  into your vagina the speculum will be  opened so that your cervix can be seen  next your provider will use a scraper or  brush to gently collect cells from your  cervix  your cells will be examined at a lab  under a microscope to see if any of them  are abnormal  it usually takes about one to three  weeks to get your test results  if you have questions about this test or  your test results talk to your provider